most of our audience knows that the year
is 2020. we are one of the richest
countries in the world
and there are endless food lines
in texas of people lining up at a food
bank
to get food more than 6 000 cars and 25
000
people lined up to get free food from
the north texas food bank
this is the largest food giveaway ever
by this food bank most people in the
line
received a turkey some dry products
bread and fresh produce each person was
given about 20 meals worth of food
according to the food bank at least 40
percent of the people
waiting for food were new to that food
bank and there
because of the virus there's a report
from the institute for policy research
at northwestern university from june
which reported
that food insecurity has doubled in the
united states
and tripled for families with kids as a
result of the pandemic
and when you look at the pictures and
video of this and you realize
this is optional you have to be asking
questions about why this
is going on we are not a country with no
money
and lacking resources we throw out
a third or more of the food that we
produce it's even more if you count all
stages of the food production process
including stuff that's left
in the fields because it would not be
physically attractive enough
to be worth it to send to a grocery
store we have a president
that in the midst of this pandemic is
just absent donald trump has not taken
questions in weeks
uh in the time since the election he's
only been seen
three times once was 2 am on election
night claiming he won
one was laying a wreath on veterans day
and one was taking credit
a week ago for coronavirus vaccines that
are upcoming reportedly
without taking a single question he's
not answered a single question from the
media in weeks
and we have food lines as the president
is gone he's played golf twice in the
last week
but he's not spoken to the media in
three weeks remember when donald trump
jr
talked about how this is america we
don't have
the food lines the breadlines like he
supposedly saw
in supposedly communist countries well
we do have them
he's just wrong i guess these would i
guess the difference is these are
capitalist bread lines
rather than communist bread lines for
all the talk about
communist bread lines and this will
never be a socialist country
this seems pretty damn dystopian to me
this is texas
a capitalist state in the us a
capitalist country
filled the state and the country with
capitalists everywhere
socialism and communism are now just
euphemisms
for anything republicans don't like for
the government doing something we know
that at this point
and by the way how many people in the
breadlines
were the very people decrying socialist
breadlines along with donald trump on
twitter just months ago
it is texas after all it's as much a red
state as it is a blue state although it
was close this election
the real socialism is that the red
states
and in particular red counties are
regularly
bailed out by blue states and blue
counties think about this
on average red states are dramatically
more dependent on the federal government
than blue states and in fact the blue
states
are subsidizing the red states by paying
in more to the federal government than
they get
out while the red states on average get
much more from the federal government
than they pay in
but then you can go even further look at
it at the county level
the counties that donald trump won in
the election in the whole country
only contribute to 30 percent of our
overall economy
the counties joe biden one contribute
70 to the overall economy economy so
think of those numbers and think of the
hypocrisy of these people
talking about self-sufficiency and
pulling yourself up by your bootstraps
and dependence on the government
it's the red counties and the red states
that overwhelmingly depend
on the blue counties and the blue states
they'll never admit it
they'll never even understand it they'll
never hear about it
and yet we have the very same breadlines
that donald trump jr and others decry
as merely a feature or a bug i guess
depending on your perspective
of so-called socialist and communist
countries it's pathetic guys
we have real problems to solve and trump
is just missing
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information
so this allows you to keep your banking
information secure
but also to take control of your
finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches
and identity theft and it's free there's
no catch whatsoever but if
you want privacy also offers a ten
dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36
credit cards a month and a 25 a month
plan tailored more for small businesses
where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.gov slash pacman